PATRICK WINSTON: Ladies and
gentlemen, the Romanian
national anthem.
I did not ask you to stand,
because I didn't play it as a
symbol of Romanian national
identity.
But rather, to celebrate the
end of the Cold War, which
occurred about the time
that you were born.
Before that, no one came to
MIT from Eastern Europe.
But since that time, we've been
blessed by having in our
midst Lithuanians, Estonians,
Poles, Czecs, Slovaks,
Bulgarians, Romanians,
Slovenians, Serbs, and all
sorts of people from regions
of the world
formally excluded to us.
Believe me, you are all
welcome in our house.
Almost all, that is to say.
Because you may recall that
Romania is the traditional
home of vampires.
And since the end of the Cold
War, vampires have had new
vectors for emerging from their
traditional places and
penetrating into the
world at large.
You may have vampire in your
suite, or on your floor.
And it's important to know how
to recognize them, and take
the necessary precautions.
So if you have this concern, I
would expect that the first
thing you would do would be to
look at some data concerning
the characteristics
of vampires.
So there's a little database of
samples of individuals who
have been determined to be
vampires and not vampires.
And our task today--
and what you'll understand how
to do by the end of the hour--
is to use data like this to
build a recognition mechanism
that would help you to identify
whether someone is a
vampire or an ordinary person.
So this is a little different
from the kind of problem we
worked with neural nets.
Right?
So what's the most conspicuous
difference between this data
set and anything you could think
to work on with nearest
neighbors, which we
studied last time.
Katie, do you have any thoughts
about why it would be
difficult to use nearest
neighbors with data like this?
The question mark is there
because this is MIT, and a lot
of people are completely
nocturnal.
So you can't tell whether they
cast a shadow or not.
We want to take that
into account.
So what's different about
this from the
electrical cover data set?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PATRICK WINSTON: Could you use
the nearest neighbor technique
to identify vampires
with this data?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PATRICK WINSTON:
So obviously--
Yes, Lana?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
STUDENT: You cannot
really quantify--
PATRICK WINSTON: Oh,
that's the problem.
This is not numerical data.
This is symbolic.
So we're not saying that
your ability to
cast a shadow is 0.7.
You either cast a shadow,
down cast a
shadow, or we can't tell.
It's a symbolic result.
So problem number one we have to
face with data of this kind
is that it's not numeric.
And there are other
characteristics, as well.
For example, it's not clear
that all of these
characteristics actually
matter.
So some characteristics
don't matter.
And a corollary to that is that
some characteristics do
matter, but they only matter
part of the time.
And finally, there's
the matter of cost.
Some of these tests may
be more expensive to
perform than others.
For example, if you wanted to
determine whether someone
casts a shadow, you'd have to
go to the trouble of getting
up during daylight.
That might be an expensive
operation for you.
You'd have to go find some
garlic and ask them to eat it.
That might be expensive.
So some of these tests
might be expensive
relative to other tests.
But once you realize that we are
talking in terms of tests,
and not a vector of
real values, then
what you do is clear.
You build yourself a little
tree of tests.
So who knows how this problem
will turn out?
But you can imagine a situation
where you have one
test up here which might
have three outcomes.
And one but only one of those
outcomes might require you to
perform another test.
And only when you've created
the tree of tests that look
like this are you finished.
So given this set of tests and a
set of samples, the question
becomes, how do you arrange the
tests in a tree like that
so as to do the identification
that you want to do?
So since we're talking about
identification, it's not
surprising that this kind
of tree is called an
identification tree.
And there's a tendency-- and I
may slip into it myself-- to
call this a decision tree.
But a decision tree is a label
for something else.
This is an identification
tree.
And the task is to create
a good one.
So what is a good one versus
a not so good one?
What characteristic would you
like for a decision tree--
for an identification trade to
have, if you're going to call
it good identification tree?
What do you think, Krishna?
What would be a good
characteristic?
STUDENT: Maybe the minimum
number of levels?
PATRICK WINSTON: Yeah.
He said minimum number
of levels.
What's another way you could
say what a good one is?
Each test costs something,
right?
So what's another way of
thinking about what a good
tree would look like?
STUDENT: Minimum cost.
PATRICK WINSTON: The
minimum cost.
And if they all have the
same cost, then it's
the number of tests.
So overall, what you like
is a small tree
rather than a big one.
So you might be able to take
your sample data and divide it
up, so that at the bottom of the
tree, at the leaves, all
of the sets that are produced
by the tests are uniform,
homogeneous.
We'd like that tree to be the
simplest possible tree you can
find, not some big complicated
one that also divides up all
the data into uniform subsets.
By uniform subset--
at the bottom of the tree, you
have all of the vampires
together, and all the
non-vampires together.
So you'd like a small tree.
So why not just go all the way
and do British Museum, and
calculate all possible trees?
Well, you can do that, but it's
one of those NP problems.
And as you know, NP problems
suck in general.
And so you don't want
to do that.
You want to have some kind of
heuristic mechanism for
building a small tree.
And we want a small
tree because--
Why do we want a small tree?
Because of the cost.
but there's another, more
important reason why we want a
small tree.
Let me give you a hint.
It's Occam's Razor.
The simplest explanation is
often the best explanation.
So if you have a big,
complicated explanation,
that's probably less good than
a simple, small explanation.
Occam's Razor.
Spelled so many ways it doesn't
matter how I spell it.
And that's good, because
I can't spell.
So how are we going to go
about finding the best
possible arrangement
of those four tests
in a tree like that?
Well, step one will be
to see what each test
does with the data.
And by the way, before I go a
step further, you know and I
know that this is a sample data
set that's very small,
suitable for classroom
manipulation.
You'd never bet your life on
a data set this small.
We use it only for classroom
illustration.
But imagine that these rows
are multiplied by 10.
So instead of eight samples,
you've got 80.
Then you might begin
to believe the
results that are produced.
So I'm just going to pretend
that each one of those
represents 10 other
samples that I
haven't bothered to show.
But we can work with this one in
the classroom, because it's
pretty small.
And we can say, well, what
does this shadow test do?
Well, the shadow test divides
the sample population into
three groups.
There's the I Don't Know group
of people who are nocturnal.
There are the people
who do cast the
shadow, the Yes people.
And the people who do not cast
a shadow, the No people.
So if I look at those rows up
there and see which ones are
vampires, it looks to me that
if there's no shadow cast--
there's only one that doesn't
cast a shadow--
and that is a vampire.
So that's a plus over there.
Vampire.
Now, if we look at the ones
who do cast a shadow, all
those are not vampires.
They're all OK.
And now there're 8.
Three are vampires.
So that means that two of
these must be vampires.
And I've got three, four,
five, six so far.
So there must be two left.
So that's the way the shadow
test divides up the data.
Now let's do garlic.
Vampires traditionally
don't eat garlic.
I don't know why.
So we look at the garlic
test, and we see
that all of the Nos--
well, there're three
Yeses, and they all
produce a No answer.
So if somebody eats garlic,
they're not vampires.
That means the three vampires
must be over here.
Then there are two left.
So that's what the
garlic test does.
See what we're trying to do?
We're trying to look at all
these tests to see which one
we like best on the basis of
how it divides up the data.
So now we've got complexion.
And there are three
choices for this.
You can have an average
complexion.
But a lot of vampires, in my
experience, are rather pale.
So pale is a possibility.
And then the other option is
that just after gorging
themselves with blood,
they tend to get a
little red in the face.
So we'll have a ruddy
over here.
Once again, we have to go back
to our data set to see how
this test divides things up.
So there are three ruddies, and
one's a No, one's a No,
and one's a Yes.
So two Nos and a Yes.
Two Nos and a Yes.
Now we can try for pale
complexion people.
There are only two of those.
A No and a No.
That must mean that there are
two pluses over here, because
there are three vampires
altogether.
Two, four, six, seven,
eight, nine.
Eight, sorry.
Eight.
Only eight.
Just one more to go, and
that's the accent.
Historically, vampires go to
great length to protect their
accent and not betray
their origins.
But nevertheless, we
can expect that if
they've just arrived--
if they're just in from
Transylvania, part of Romania--
they may still have an accent.
So there's a normal, some still
have a heavy accent, and
some persist in having
odd accents.
So let's see.
Accent.
Four of them, right at the
top, have no accent.
Two Nos and a Yes.
Heavy accent.
Three of those.
A Yes and two Nos.
That means we must
have a plus here.
3, 6, plus and a minus.
So we can look at this data and
say, well, what will be
the best test to use?
And the best test to use would
surely be the one that
produces sets here, at the
bottom of the branches, that
correspond to the outcomes
of the test.
We're looking for a test that
produces homogeneous groups.
So just for the sake of
illustration, I'm going to
suppose that we're going to
judge the quality of the test
by how many sample individuals
it put into a homogeneous set.
So ideally, we'd like a test
that will put all the vampires
in one group and all the
ordinary people in another
group right off the bat.
But there are no such tests.
But we can add up the number of
sample individuals who are
put in to at least
homogeneous sets.
So when we do that, this
guy has 3 in a
homogeneous set here.
A fourth.
But these are not a
homogeneous set.
So the overall score for
this guy will be 4.
This one, well, not
quite as good.
It only puts 3 individuals
in a homogeneous set.
This one here, 2 individuals
into a homogeneous set.
Everybody else is all
mixed up with some
other kind of person.
And over here, how many
samples are in
a homogeneous set?
0.
So on the basis of this
analysis, you would conclude
that the ordering of the test
with respect to their quality
is left to right.
So the best test must
be the shadow test.
So let's pick the shadow
test first, see what
we can do with that.
If we pick the shadow test
first, then we have this
arrangement.
We have question mark, and we
have Yes, casts a shadow, and
No, doesn't.
We have 3 minuses here.
We have a plus here.
And unfortunately, over
here, we have plus,
plus, minus, minus.
So we need another test to
divide that group up.
Yes.
STUDENT: How did you get the
4 on the shadow test again?
Why was it 4?
PATRICK WINSTON: Well,
if I look at the
data and I see who--
the question is, what about
that shadow test?
If you look at the shadow test,
and you say, well, there
are 4 question marks.
And if we look and see what kind
of people belong to those
4 question marks, there are 2
vampires and 2 non-vampires.
That's why it's 2 pluses
and 2 minuses.
STUDENT: No, I understand
that.
The question is, how did you
get to the score of 4?
PATRICK WINSTON: Oh, yeah.
The question is how did
I get this number 4?
It has nothing to do this,
because this is a mixed set.
In fact, I've got three guys in
a homogeneous set here, and
one guy in a homogeneous
set here, and I'm
just adding them up.
STUDENT: OK.
PATRICK WINSTON: So very simple
classroom illustration.
Wouldn't work in practice.
Yes.
STUDENT: How do you adjust
this for larger data sets
where it's unlikely you're going
to have any [INAUDIBLE]?
PATRICK WINSTON: The question
is, how do I adjust this for
larger data sets?
You're one step ahead.
Trust me, I'll be doing large
data sets in a moment.
I just want to get
the idea across.
And I don't want there to be any
thought that the method we
use for larger data sets has got
anything magic about it.
OK, so we're off and running.
And now we have to pick a
test that will divide
those four guys up.
So we're going to have to work
this a little harder, and
repeat the analysis
we did there.
But at least it'll be simpler,
because now we're only
considering 4 samples, not 8.
Just the 4 samples that we still
have to divide up that
have come down that
left branch.
So I have the shadow test.
It has 3 outcomes.
We have the garlic test.
It has 2 outcomes.
Yes and No.
We have the complexion test.
There's 3 outcomes.
Average, pale, and ruddy.
And we have finally
the accent test.
And that comes out to be either
normal, heavy, or odd.
And now, it's a little awkward
to figure out what the results
are for this data
set as shown.
So let me just strike out.
The ones that we're no longer
concerned with, and limit our
analysis to the samples for
which the outcome of the
shadow test is a
question mark.
This is exactly the four
people we still need to
separate, right?
So switching colors, keeping
the color the same.
We actually don't want
to do the shadow
test anymore, right?
Because we've already
done that.
There's no point in
doing that again.
We don't have to look at that.
It's already done all the
division of data that it can.
So the garlic test.
Well, let's see.
Garlic.
2 Yeses, 2 Nos.
The Yeses produce Nos and
the Nos produce Yeses.
So if the person does eat
garlic, they're OK.
And if they don't eat garlic,
bad news-- they're vampires.
Well, that looks like
a pretty good test.
But just for the sake of working
it all out, let's try
the others.
Complexion.
2 Ruddies, a Yes, and a No.
1 pale, and that's a No.
And we must have 1 average, and
sure enough, that's a Yes.
Now we can do accent, the one on
the far right, and look at
how that measures up against the
people who are still under
consideration as samples.
Accent.
Let's see.
2 Nones, a Yes and a No.
No Heavies.
2 Odds, a Yes and a No.
All right.
So now we can do the same thing
we did before, and just
say, for sake of classroom
illustration, how many
individuals are put into
a homogeneous sets.
And here we have 4.
And here we have 2.
And here we have 0.
So plainly, the garlic test
is the test of choice.
So we go back over here, and
we've completed the work that
we needed to do.
So that's the garlic test.
And that produces 2 pluses.
Let's see.
Eats garlic, Yes.
Eats garlic, No.
I guess the pluses go
over here like so.
And these are the two
ordinary people.
And we're done with our task.
And now you can quickly run
off and put this into your
PDA, and forever be protected
against the possibility that
one of those vampires got out
in the flood of people that
came in from Eastern Europe.
Except what do we do
a large data set?
Well, the trouble is,
a large data set's
not likely to produce--
if you have a large data set,
no test is likely to put
together any homogeneous
set right off.
So you never get started.
Everything would be 0.
Every test would say, oh it
doesn't put anybody into
homogeneous sets.
So you're screwed.
You need some other, more
sophisticated way of measuring
how disordered this data is.
Or how disordered these sets
are that you find at the
bottom of the tree branches.
That's what you need.
You need a way of measuring
disorder of these sets that
you find at the bottom of these
branches, so you can
find a kind of overall quality
to the test based on your
measurement of disorder.
Now, the first heuristic of a
good life is, when you have a
problem to solve, ask somebody
who knows the answer.
It's the least amount of work.
It's not even as hard
going to Google.
So who would you ask
about ways of
measuring disorder in sets?
There are two possible
answers.
STUDENT: You could
just do entropy.
PATRICK WINSTON: What?
STUDENT: Find the entropy
of the set.
PATRICK WINSTON: Who
studies entropy?
STUDENT: Probability.
PATRICK WINSTON: What
kind of classes?
STUDENT: Physics.
STUDENT: Thermodynamics.
PATRICK WINSTON:
Thermodynamics!
The thermodynamicists are good
at measuring disorder, because
that's what thermodynamics
is all about.
Entropy increasing over time,
and all that sort of stuff.
There's another equally
good answer.
STUDENT: Statisticians?
PATRICK WINSTON:
Statisticians.
Perhaps, but it's not the
second best answer.
It's actually not even
the best answer.
That's the best answer.
What's your name?
STUDENT: Leo.
PATRICK WINSTON: Oh, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
PATRICK WINSTON: Leonardo has
got his finger on it.
The information theorists are
pretty good at measuring
disorder, because that's what
information is all about, too.
So we might as well borrow a
mechanism for measuring the
disorder of a set from those
information theory guys.
So what we're going to
do is exactly that.
Let's put it over here, so we'll
have it handy when we
want to try to measure
those things.
The gospel according to
information theorists is that
the disorder, D, or some set
is equal to-- now let's
suppose that this is a
set of binary values.
So we have positives and
then we have negatives.
Pluses and minuses.
But pluses, they don't go very
well in an algebraic equation,
because they might be confused
with adding.
So I'm going to say P and N. And
then it'll be the total,
which is P plus N. We only
have two choices,
positive and negative.
So the disorder of set,
according those guys, is equal
to minus the number of positives
over the total
number, times the log to the
base 2 of the positives over
the total, minus the negatives
over the total, times the log
2 of the negatives
over the total.
Those negatives look a little
worrisome, because you think,
well, maybe this thing
can go negative.
But that's not going
to be true, right?
Because these ratios are all
less than 1, and the logarithm
of something that's less
than 1 is negative.
So we're OK.
So that's a lovely way of
measuring disorder.
And then we ought to draw
a graph of what
that curve looks like.
And what we're going to graph
it against is the ratio of
positives to the total number.
So that's going to be an axis
where we go from 0 to 1.
So let's just find a couple
of useful values.
And by the way, it pays to pay
attention to these curves,
because if you pay attention
to this stuff, you can work
the quiz questions on
this very rapidly.
Otherwise, we see people getting
out their calculators
and quickly becoming both
lost and screwed.
OK so let's see.
Let's suppose that the number
of positives is equal to the
number of negatives.
So we've got a completely
mixed-up set.
It has no bias in either
direction.
So in that case, if P over T is
equal to 1/2, then this is
equal to minus 1/2, times
the logarithm of 1/2.
And I guess, since they're
both the same, we
can multiply by two.
And what's that value?
[INAUDIBLE], what does that
calculate out to?
STUDENT: Minus [INAUDIBLE]
PATRICK WINSTON: Minus
[INAUDIBLE].
Well, with a minus sign, you
just turn the argument upside
down, so it's log(2).
So what's log(2)?
Logarithm of base 2 of 2?
1!
So this whole thing is--
STUDENT: 1.
PATRICK WINSTON: 1.
So [INAUDIBLE], in her soft way,
says, well, let's see.
2 times 1/2.
That cancels out.
The minus, that flips the
arguments so it's log to the
base 2 of 2, and that's 1.
So this whole thing, You
work out the algebra,
it gives you 1.
So that's cool.
So right here in the middle
where they're equal, we get a
value of 1.
Next thing we need to do is
let's calculate what happens
if P over T is equal to 1.
That is to say, everything
is a positive.
Any guesses?
Maybe 10, 20, minus 15?
Let's work it out.
So if P over T equal 1, that
would be minus 1 times the log
to the base 2 of 1.
What's that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PATRICK WINSTON: A 0?
Oh, yeah.
Because 2 raise to
the 0 is one.
So this part is 0.
Now, what about this
other part?
If everything's a P, then
nothing's an N.
So we've got 0.
And we can quit already.
Well, not quite.
We ought to work it out.
Log 2 to the base 2 of 0.
What's that?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PATRICK WINSTON: Who?
Minus infinity?
Uh oh.
0 times minus infinity is What
I didn't get that when I was
in high school.
Finally, 1801 makes
a difference.
Finally.
What's the answer.
We're interested in the limit as
N over T goes to 0, right?
And when you have a deal like
this, what do you do?
You use that famous rule, that
we all mispronounce when we
see it written, right?
We use the good old El
Hospital's rule.
OK, it's L'Hopital.
L'Hopital's Rule.
You have to differentiate
the--
I guess we differentiate this
guy as a ratio or something,
and see what happens
when it goes to 0.
And what we get when we use
L'Hopital's Rule is that, oh
thank God, this is still zero.
So now we know that we have a
point up there and a point
down there.
So now we've got three
points on the curve,
and we can draw it.
It goes like that.
No, it doesn't go like that.
It's obviously a Gaussian,
right?
Because everything in a
nature is a Gaussian.
Can you put that laptop
away, please?
Everything in nature
is a Gaussian, so
it looks like this.
That right?
No, actually, not everything
in nature is a Gaussian.
And in particular, this one
isn't a Gaussian either.
It looks more like one of those
metal things they used
to call quonset huts.
That's what it looks like.
Boom, like so.
So that is the curve
of interest.
Now, did God say that using this
way of measuring disorder
was the best way?
No, Got has not indicated
any choice here.
We use this because it's a
convenient mechanism, it seems
to make sense, but in contrast
to the reason it's used
information theory, it's not
the result of some elegant
mathematics.
It's just a borrowing of
something that seems to work
pretty well.
Any of those curves would work
just about the same, because
all we're doing with
it is measuring how
disordered a set is.
So one thing to note here is
that in this situation, where
we're dealing with
two choices--
P and N, positives
and negatives--
we get a curve that
maxes out at one.
And notice that it kind of gets
up there pretty fast.
In fact, if you're down here
at 2/3, are you're up here,
this is about 0.9.
So it gives you a large number
for quite a bit of that area
in the middle.
So that, unfortunately, still
doesn't tell us everything we
need to know.
That tells us how to measure a
disorder in one of these sets.
But we want to know how to
measure the quality of the
test overall.
So we need some mechanism that
says, OK, given that this test
produces three different sets,
and we now have a measure of
the disorder in each of these
sets, how do we measure the
overall quality of the test?
Well, you could just add
up the disorder.
Let's write that down, because
that sounds good.
So you can say that the quality
of a test is equal to
some sum over the
sets produced.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to add up the
disorder of each
of those sets.
I'm almost home, except that
this means we're going to give
equal weight to a branch that
has almost nothing down it--
we're going to give the same
weight to that as a branch
that has almost everything
going down it.
So that doesn't seem
that make sense.
So one final flourish is we're
going to weight this sum
according to the fraction of the
samples that end up down
that branch.
So it's, as usual, easier to
write it down than to say it.
So we're going to multiply
that times the number of
samples in the set, divided
by the number of
samples handled by test.
So if half the samples go down
a branch, and if that branch
has a certain disorder, then
we're going to multiply that
disorder times 1/2.
All right.
So now let's see how it works
with our sample problem.
Well, here is our sample data.
And we didn't need anything
fancy for it.
But let's pretend it was
a large data set.
Well, let's see.
What would we do?
Well, go down this
way, there are 4
samples down that direction.
That's half of the total
number of samples.
So whatever we find down
there, we're going
to multiply by 1/2.
This one we're going
to multiply by 3/8.
And this one we're going
to multiply by 1/8.
Now, what do we actually find at
the bottom of these things?
Well, here's a homogeneous
set.
Everything's the same.
So we go to that curve and say,
what is the disorder of a
homogeneous set?
It's zero.
Let's see, they're
all the same.
I guess that means it's
0 over there.
So the disorder of this set
of three samples is zero.
The disorder of this set
of one sample, all
the same, is zero.
The disorder of this set--
well, let's see.
Half of the samples there are
plus, and half are minus, so
we go over to our curve, and we
say, what's the disorder of
something with equal mixture
of pluses and minuses?
And that's one.
So the disorder of
this guy is one.
So now we've got 1/2 times 1,
and 3/8 times 0, 1/8 times 0.
So the quality of this
particular test, as determined
by the disorder of the sets
it produces, is 1/5.
0.5.
Let's do this one.
So we have 3/8 coming
down this way, 5/8
coming down this way.
3/8 is multiplied by
the disorder of a
set of uniform things.
That's disorder 0.
So this guy over here,
let's see.
That's 2/5 and 3/5
multiplied--
You know, this is one of those
deals where if you look at the
curve, you're pretty close
to the middle.
And that curve goes all the
way up to about 0.9 there.
So you can kind of just look at
this, and eyeball it, and
say, well, whatever it is, the
overall, this is going to be
something multiplied
times 5/8.
Something like 0.9 times 5/8.
So let's just say, for the
sake of discussion, that
that's going to be about 0.6,
which is within a hundredth, I
think, of being right.
Just kind of guessing.
OK, well now we're on a roll.
Here, we have 3/8 coming down
this branch, 3/8 coming down
this branch, 1/4 coming
down this branch.
This is 0.
And this is one of those deals
where these two are about 0.9.
So it looks like it's going
to be 3/8 plus 3/8 is 3/4.
Times about 0.9.
So that's going to turn
out to be about 0.7.
So one last go here.
3/8, 3/8, and 1/4.
Oh, that's interesting.
Because these two
are what we got
contributed up to that 0.7.
This one is 0.4 times--
this is evenly divided,
so that's going to
have disorder of 1.
So that's going to be
0.25 bigger than the
number we got over here.
So that's going to end
up being about 0.95.
So thanks god our answer is the
same as we got with our
simple classroom measurement
of disorder.
Except this is measuring how
disordered stuff is, we want
the small number, not
the big number.
So once again, based on this
analysis, you'll be sure to
pick the shadow cast, because
0.5 is less than 0.6, which is
less than 0.7, which
is less than 0.95.
So that accent test is
really horrible.
Don't use it.
Just because somebody has a
heavy accent doesn't mean
they're a vampire.
In fact, most vampires have
worked very hard on their
accent, as I mentioned before.
All right, so now we know that
we're still going to pick the
shadow test as our first go.
So that's good.
Now, let's see if we can repeat
the exercise with our
second selection, the one we
have to have to pick those
guys apart.
And this is going to be easier,
because there are
fewer things to work with.
Ooh, wow, look.
That's 0.
That's 1/2.
So the disorder of
this guy is 0.0.
So this is 1/4, 1/4,
1/2, 0, 0.
1/2 times 1.
Ooh, that's 0.5.
That was easy.
How about this one?
Oh, he says 1.
Let's see.
That's 1.
That's 1/2.
Yeah, it is one.
So sure enough, the answer also
comes out to be the same
as before, when we did our just
simple intuition exercise.
So I don't know.
Christopher, is this all about
using information theory?
STUDENT: No.
PATRICK WINSTON: No, no, no.
See, it's not about the math.
It's about the intuition.
And the intuition is that you
want to build a tree that's as
simple as possible.
And you can build a tree that's
as simple as possible
if you look at the data, and
say, well, which test does the
best job of splitting
things up?
Which test does the best job of
building subsets underneath
it that are as homogeneous
as possible?
So all this information theory,
all this entropy
stuff, is just a convenient
mechanism for doing something
that is intuitionally sound.
OK?
It's not about information
theory.
It's about a sound intuition.
Oh, by the way.
Does this kind of stuff ever
get used in practice?
10s of thousands of times.
This is a winning mechanism
that's used over and over
again, even when the
data is numeric.
How would it work if
it's numeric data?
Well, let's think about
that for a little bit.
So let's suppose that we
have an opportunity.
We're an EMT or something,
we work in the infirmary.
What do they call
it these days?
Something else.
But anyhow, you work in that
kind of area, and you have the
opportunity to take people's
temperature.
And so over time, you've
accumulated some data on the
temperature of people.
And maybe you've found that
there's a vampire
here at about 102.
There's a normal person
here, about 98.6.
But then they're scattered
around.
Some people have fevers
when they come in.
So the question is, is there a
way of using numerical data--
things that you can
put real numbers--
is there a way of using that
with this mechanism?
And the answer is yes.
You just say, is the temperature
greater than or
less than some threshold?
And that gives you a test, a
binary test, just like any of
these other tests.
[? Krishna? ?]
Right?
But where would I put
the threshold?
I suppose I could just put
it at the average value.
But that might not be the place
that does the best job
of splitting the samples into
homogeneous groups.
Christopher?
STUDENT: So you run this
numerical analysis on
different places with different
thresholds.
PATRICK WINSTON: So you try
different places, he says.
And he's right.
Because this is a computer,
this is our slave.
We don't care how much
it works to figure
out the right threshold.
So what we do is we say, well,
maybe the threshold's halfway
between those two guys, or
halfway between those two
guys, or those two guys,
or those two guys,
or those two guys.
So we can try one
less threshold
than we have samples.
And we don't care if there are
10,000 samples, because this
is a computer, and we don't care
if it works all night.
So that's how you find the
threshold for a numeric test.
By the way, I assured you
earlier on you would never use
the same test twice.
Is that true for this?
Yes, you would still never
use the same test twice.
But what you might do is you
might use a different
threshold on the same
measurement
the next time around.
So when you start having
numerical data, you may find
yourself using the same test
with the same axis but with a
different value.
All right.
So now that we have this, then
we can go back and compare how
this method would look when we
put it up against the sort of
stuff we were talking about
last time, with
the electrical covers.
So with the electrical covers,
we had a situation like this.
I don't know.
We had samples that were places
like this, and we had a
division of the space that look
pretty much like that.
Not quite exactly in the right
spots, but pretty close.
So these are the decision
boundaries for the situation
where we are using nearest
neighbors to
divide up the data.
What would the decision
boundaries look like if these
were four different kinds of
things, and we were using this
kind of mechanism?
And maybe there's a lot of
samples all clustered around
places like that.
What would the decision
boundaries look like?
Would they be the
same as this?
god, I hope not.
Why?
Because what we're going to
do is we're going to use a
threshold on each axis.
So therefore, the decision
boundaries are going to be
parallel to one axis
or the other.
So we might decide,
for example--
Oh, shoot.
I think I'll draw it again,
because it'll get confused if
I draw it over the other one.
So it looks like this.
And that's how nearest
neighbors does it.
But a identification tree
approach will pick a threshold
along one axis or the other.
Let's say it's this axis.
It's only got one
choice there.
So it's going to put
a line there.
And now, what's the next
thing it does?
Well, it still has these
two different kinds
of things to separate.
We're going to assume
we've got four
different kinds of things.
So it's going to say, oh!
I've Come down the negative
side, so I need a threshold on
the remaining data.
And these are the only two
things that are now remaining.
So my only choice is to put
a threshold in there.
Now I guarantee this, absolutely
guaranteed--
on the quiz, somebody--
presumably somebody who doesn't
go to lectures--
will draw that line all
the way across.
And that's desperately wrong.
Because we've already divided
this data set in half.
Now the choice of what we do
over here is governed only by
the remaining samples that
we see, these two.
And so the threshold is going
to go in there like that.
So that's what happens
when you go back.
This is used 10s of thousands
of times.
Always used.
What are the virtues of it?
Number one, you don't
use all the tests.
You use only the test that seem
to be doing some useful
work for you.
So that means that you do a
better job, because your
measurement technique
is simpler.
And it costs less, because
you're not going to the
expense of doing all
of the testing.
So it's a real winner.
But you know what?
Some classes of people--
not scientists, but I mean
people like doctors and stuff.
They don't like to look
at these tress.
They're kind of rule-oriented.
So they look a tree like this
for determining what kind of
thyroid disease you have, and
it would have maybe 20 or so
tests in it of various kinds
of hormones, like thyroxine
and this and that.
And they say, ah, we can't
deal with that.
So we have to work with them.
So what we do is we convert the
tree into a set of rules.
How do we convert the tree
into a set of rules?
Oops, wrong one.
Go away, go away.
Here's what I want.
Yeah, good.
How would we convert this tree
into a set of rules?
It's straightforward.
[INAUDIBLE], what do we do?
STUDENT: You'd basically just
look down each branch--
PATRICK WINSTON: You'd basically
just go down each
branch to a leaf.
So you say, for example,
here's one rule.
If shadow equals question mark,
and garlic equals oh,
[INAUDIBLE]
want to choose No.
Doesn't eat garlic.
No.
I think I'll say Yes.
Yes.
That changes the answer.
Then if it eats garlic, it's
not a vampire, right?
That's one of four possible
rules, because there are four
leaf nodes.
Now, almost done.
We are done, except
for one thing.
We can actually take these four
rules, and start thinking
about how to simplify them.
You can ask questions like, if
I have a rule that tests both
the shadow and the garlic, do I
actually need both of those
antecedents?
And the answer is, in
many cases, no.
And in particular,
in this case, no.
Because if we look at our data
set, what we discover is that
in the event that we're
talking about a shadow
question mark--
oh, I guess I had a better
choice the other way.
Oh, no.
If you look at the garlic,
all the garlics--
Yes, Yes, and Yes--
it turns out that the answer is
no, independent of what the
shadow condition is.
So we can look at the rules,
and in some cases, we'll
discover that our tree is a
little bit more complicated
than it needs to be.
We can actually get rid of
some of the clauses.
So in the end, we can develop a
very simple mechanism based
on good old fashioned rule-based
behavior, like you
saw almost in the beginning
of the subject,
that does the job.
And now, without any royalty,
you're all free to put this in
your PDA and use it to protect
yourself in the days to com,
especially since Halloween's
just around the corner.